I never thought I'd be wrestling at 51.
I also didn't think I'd have a career
here at 51 either so once again you got
to follow the story and see where it
takes you and so far it's been uh it's
been a great year and I feel awesome so
there's no reason to even think about
stopping when you have an embolism what
does that feel like couldn't breathe
like literally I was on stage with
Fozzie and I couldn't sing I couldn't
catch my breath and I was like this is
weird and I started hearing a blood clot
uh because I talked to a couple doctors
that I knew here and lo and behold I had
a day off in London went got some blood
tests and I said you gotta go right to
the hospital you got you've got uh blood
clots pulmonary embolism which I mean
people die from that so you're in the
hospital yeah in London in a foreign
country right before Christmas what do
they do for you how do they how do they
well right away you got to start getting
blood thinners and they bring this
freaking needle and they stick it right
in your thigh and it's like ah the blood
thinner's got to get in there right away
to start tearing them apart essentially
so that was the first thing and then the
ox like you know the oxygen level was
really bad because you can't breathe and
that's something I think during covid
time everyone was checking their oxygen
levels supposed to be at like 99 or 100
yeah mine was like down at like 92.
couldn't walk from here to that couch
they'll be like
it was it was how long were you in that
shape before you went and checked
yourself it was quick it was quick that
got to that point so at the beginning of
the tour the first three shows were
great fourth one I started feeling weird
and I lasted about another three days
after that before I went to the hospital
so it was it hit very quick Onslaught
was like boom and that's how people die
from it because you don't know no one
knows if you have blood clots are you
supposed to know that it's like you have
like a I had no symptoms or anything it
just horrible guy normal day and
suddenly I can't breathe so it was
really kind of like when you hear that
people die of these you can understand
how because you don't know when did this
happen December of last year December of
21. wow yeah wow but yeah family must
have freaked they freaked because once
again you're stuck overseas too nobody's
there and when you're in the hospital at
any time it's kind of scary because you
never know like oh what if right right
when you're in the hospital this is once
again you know during covid times so the
level starts going down and then they
put the the oxygen in your nose and I'm
like the next step is the intubation
yeah the freaking ventilator and then
you start to start freaking out and I
was like I'm not getting in a wheelchair
to go to these tests I'm not putting on
this gown you got to put on this gown no
I don't you got to get this wheelchair
no I'm walking I'm walking where I need
to go why because I was scared like
everything that would like if I get into
a wheelchair and put the hospital thing
on that's one step closer to in my head
never getting out like you start I was
reading so you're sitting there fully
dressed getting on these well I had gym
shorts and a tank top or whatever it was
I just didn't want to accept the the
the you know the hospital gown like it
just all of it was just in my head like
what if I never got out of here you know
what if I don't get out of here and you
start thinking that way it's it's freaky
how long are you in that was only two
days but it felt like two months because
you didn't know the things if someone
said you're going to the hospital for
two days you're gonna go out at 6 p.m on
Thursday you're like all right you're
going to the hospital and we don't know
when you're gonna get out that's a scary
problem so you went you couldn't breathe
in did you go have a doctor check you
outside that said go to the hospital
like that we had a rock doc there's guys
that come to your hotel that deal with
bands right or so we had the rock dot
come see him he took some he took some
blood and then three hours later I was
supposed to go for a heart test he goes
no heart test you're going straight to
the hospital so you go to the ER yeah go
right into the hospital and thankfully
it was with like uh it's called a
medical concierge which is like a um a
company that takes care of everything
you don't have to call for appointments
you don't have to book yourself oh the
lights just went up it's okay this is
because the story the story is like now
we got to really get serious if we can
we dim the rest of the lights too please
everything went out there we go is that
better yes better thank you good um but
yes so so so it was like the rock dog
came go straight to the hospital and so
they they organized the hospital for me
which was a nice hospital so it was it
you know it was scary but it could have
been way way worse so but yeah so then
then once you get out of the hospital
well wait so let's go you're in the
hospital they're asking you to put on
the Gown they're saying they give you
this thing on the like there's got to be
a period where you go I don't like
you're saying I don't know where the
[ __ ] this is going yeah when how long
before it started getting better or what
did you notice if somebody came in yeah
so like I said they couldn't have been
better as far as treatment all that
stuff so so the next day they said with
these levels in your blood go down that
shows that the blood clots are
dissipating you can leave
please let me go please I'm sorry you
have to stay for another day
so then the next day they came in and
then my the because it works fast the
blood thinners work fast so then my
oxygen level is high enough where they
feel comfortable for me to leave the
clots are starting to dissipate so I'm
allowed to get out but you can't fly oh
[ __ ] we have blood clots right so I was
stuck there for another another week uh
and I was like listen if I have to be
here for a month I mean that's just the
way it is I can't get on a plane you
could die on the plane
um so a week is all it was which ended
up being not so bad but then even after
that week getting on a plane was your
thought like maybe they missed that like
yeah scary
and then when you and then yeah it was
especially flying from London back to
America yeah seven hours there's no and
you're over the ocean so halfway over
the ocean if something [ __ ] up there's
no they can't Land good luck buddy yeah
that's it were you thinking about that
on the flight I was you know but but but
I told so I was dealing with like the
head of pulmonary whatever it was called
pulmonary medicine in London he was a
professor this guy was a top level guy
and when he said you can fly that's when
I said okay because I said dude don't I
don't need to go home like I'll stay
here for Christmas if I have to and he's
like I'm not gonna let you get on the
plane unless you're absolutely certain
to be okay so once he finally gave me
the check mark I was cool so are you
still on blood thinner no so what
happened was so then that's what I kind
of incorporating the original question
it was then I went and got everything
lungs heart blood levels cholesterol
colonoscopy like you know whatever it
needed to be done I did it all and
everything was checked off every chapter
check and then finally about two months
ago taking off blood owners and I have a
clean bill bill of health which is great
you probably like you said healthier
than you've ever done yeah because I
took the warning right you get you get a
warning like that you gotta you gotta
listen to your to your body you know
listen to to the powers that be
[Music]